what this is really about is the German
spy health
Cameron recover from Yunker becoming the
Commission president so they want to
help the British get a good job in the
Commission one of the plum posts but
Cameron hasn't decided he's going to
send and you calm
Dobby for a big job until the rest of
Europe know who you're sending she
initially shouldn't come really decided
this ages it completely this is total sa
crisis stuff and Cameron initially plan
to send and Revathi I think he saw this
is a a way of making up his old boss
from self-deception office who's going
to shuffle after the cabinet at the next
reshuffle here's the consolation prize
go to Brussels and have a lovely time as
European Commissioner the bats idea now
seems to be definitely they realize that
they will get a pretty rubbish draw
buffet Sandman C so they are now
desperately casting around an
alternative camp well they need is
coming euro skeptic version and Nick
Clegg may need some help a big cabinet
job who speaks lots of European
languages and knows how Brussels works
there are very few people who take all
three of those boxes as well who strikes
you as a euro skeptic next leg well I
think James's point about Michael
Howard's that actually he's worked well
in this post and he will say it wouldn't
appear to be giving a job to your mate
in quite the same way although obviously
Howard was instrumental in cameras wise
to the leadership they've had something
decline there no I looked up my plans
for majority though he's a former Home
Secretary he's clearly got the kind of
CV that demands a big drop the rest of
Europe we find it very hard to say
you've sent to someone underwhelming
we're going to give you regional policy
if you look at the kind of people who
are now being sent the quality of
Commissioner is increasing quite
dramatically people are sending proper
political players from our own country I
think one of the other revealing things
about this is that the number times
desperate send the woman because John
Pullum clad said he would have more
women in senior positions and the
Barroso Commission did but so far the
Italians are the only country indicating
that they're gonna nominate a female
candidate but again
Cameron is in his quest to float women
he can't actually find anyone who thinks
he wants to promote I think is pretty
interesting about what you saying your
conscience is that the Germans are still
suggesting that we may be able to get a
decent job after all of the shenanigans
over the jean-claude Juncker the fact
that Britain isn't going to necessarily
be relegated to one of the lower down
commissioner posts that is he saying the
calling the coveted internal market
posts so lies waiting that's actually a
massive relief for David Cameron because
one of the things that his critics and
the Conservative Party was saying even
though they congratulated him on
opposing yuccas appointment was that
this would really harm British prospects
of getting a good influential job Europe
you have to do it you have to do hours
and hours and hours of spade work and
the worrying thing is you can't go into
this you can't treat
rewriting the European treaties like a
nest a crisis you can't just pick them
up and read scribble all over them to
try and make changes to put in all the
work beforehand I think that's a real
worry but number 10 is is to slapdash in
its approach to some of these things I
think that's a worry from Euroskeptics
and also year of files and the
Conservative Party generally about
Cameron's we're negotiating strategy
that he doesn't seem to be doing enough
of the groundwork now so
on the Commissioner he hasn't been
raising some meetings far enough well in
advance he surf he wasn't doing that
with Yunker even though he made a big
stand at the end he's very good at those
last minute shades of drama but he's not
so good at that quiet groundwork that
involves meeting up with people seeing
things coming down the line and it's the
same in domestic policy politics as well
the number-10 won't see something
kicking up dust in the distance until
it's basically on top of them
and he doesn't seem to be very good at
finding a woman he can trust even though
he's not so much his fault in that that
you know some of the changes he put into
voluntary selection and the like I mean
they're in the final ten years times
this will be less of a problem but I
mean the towards the tortoise problem of
women is a little bit like the England
cricket teams problem post in both
images Margaret Thatcher is the Canadian
belief in figure and the causing hat
factor everyone's looking for it for the
next factor and so people are promoted
of intrusive idiots or the classic
example of us people are promoted too
early they're thrown in at test level
when they're not ready for it they have
an all full stop and then their their
careers never quite recover from that
yeah I love it when you break it down to